so if you guys haven't been to old Vegas
old Vegas is this place where people go
to die like it's not it's not anything
like the strip that you're used to
I think it's mainly there because the
gambling is a lot cheaper and you could
see just a lot of families there and a
lot of old people who just don't give
two [ __ ] about you so we are now here
at the golden [ __ ] also known as one
of the [ __ ] ghetto is places to
[ __ ] jambul now according to Joe and
everybody else in the city of Las Vegas
the Golden Nugget is a place for a bunch
of [ __ ] degenerate and old people who
hate their life and even the dealer's
here want a job and some of the bigger
casinos so they're not as nice as them -
so we're gonna see but for me I'm a man
of positivity it's all about spending
good time with good people and I'm
pretty sure we're gonna have a great
experience at the golden [ __ ] Don
another on the dr. tan tan-tan the
golden [ __ ] here we have a bunch of
ninjas is that a real thing I guess so
all right you gotta do it - okay I'm
gonna dirty my [ __ ] socks disgusting
golden [ __ ] it is gentlemen you know me
being hospitable even though that guy
kind of said it in a very mean way you
know I'm not saying I'm a gentleman but
some [ __ ] gentleman that's that's
what I do so but there was an older man
walking through and I was gonna go open
the door for many ways but before I even
got the chance to open the door for him
he just looks at me he goes open the
door let me zip it up like hey hold that
for me oh all right I was going to do it
either way but he kind of threatened me
sighs I
it was a second or he goes off in the
second door like all right dude
I [ __ ] puck me know when you got a
gambling problem when you [ __ ] paying
double machines and [ __ ] it standing in
between playing two games that's some
[ __ ] I've never seen that before
about lucky is what his a kid I'm not
saying that I had a gambling addiction
per se but I did gamble a lot at this
place in near Sacramento called Jackson
it's Jackson right yeah yeah so Jackson
and uh I used to lose a lot of money at
that [ __ ] so I don't like gambling at
all because one chip equals a gateway
gamble so fine
if I lose 100 and I start chasing that
constantly so I didn't want to do it but
Bart forced $100 on me he goes hey this
is a hundred dollars of my money you get
to gamble it if you lose it you lose it
whatever I denied him but he shoved it
in my pocket and I was like you know
what dude I I had only about thirty
bucks left when I want it back up to 107
paid him back broke even
I don't have a gambling addiction I'm
gonna go the [ __ ] is going on here dude
just like weird if you guys cook a whole
things there's some [ __ ] weird-ass
people in this is an interesting thing
I'm not sure I'm pretty sure we can't
put it back there but that was a dude
dressed up in a leotard and another guy
just a peasant baby but the dude is a
leotard his dick was hard so he was
covering it up with the newspaper so he
gonna cover that [ __ ] up so he want to
sexually harass all the children in all
Vegas
the last of us
and then we saw this girl with pasties
with huge titties and she was like
waving people over to take pictures with
it which is perfectly fine but it wasn't
that that was scared me it was like her
her [ __ ] dude on the side that was me
mugging the [ __ ] out of people so she
wouldn't get like touched or hurt but I
don't think that was really good for
business because she's getting [ __ ]
[ __ ] add me on tender this place in
Vegas is very odd if anything if you
have nothing going for you feel like
you're gonna be homeless just being
homeless in Vegas I guaranteed you could
gamble a few dollars every day and come
up like eighty or a hundred bucks cut
your losses go home 80 100 bucks cut
your loss go home or your wins and then
go home you're good to go
Vegas has a lot of street performers
just like if you go out and Santa Monica
deli there's people who are dancing a
[ __ ] I'm not saying I'm a dancer I could
be yeah that's right but I Jesus do this
thing where they [ __ ] took that are
my name
here now
haha
if you guys notice in this like living
out loud episodes but you might see
later on there's this thing where
everybody's trying to make me do [ __ ]
that I'm scared I'm [ __ ] scared of
heights I don't like that [ __ ] these
people on this like piece of like
[ __ ] dental floss just flying across
the dumbest thing I ever seen in my life
why would you do that why would you risk
your life just live dangerously by
gambling that's it don't feed your kids
no I have to try to break my beer it's
the same thing every time I'm still
scared assembly look what you did haha
let's break this be right knit up on
that blogging Oh every did a ferris
wheel - that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fried I
saw you I couldn't get off the floor
because I stood up and I did it well
that way you just lay down the whole
time you have lost your mom College
recession it's like laying down in the
air that's a lot of money
oh no I can't do that
all pitching $10 a wall should die right
now jail is a big [ __ ] that's all I'm
gonna say she does
okay peer pressure me into all the
things that I hate and I don't you guys
may think that she does for camera but
she does to me all the time I don't
think I like being harassed if she was a
dude I would have punched in the mouth
notice that Amazon right there
sous-chef night
via a dance routine no 33 to
thank you look at him go he's a robot I
don't know if it's real or not
what
you get him down
for real for real
career
face is just a weird experience man like
it's something that I've never really
enjoyed that much but I think it's more
or less about the people that you go
with it just this just smells like piss
semen and shame
I think people like because you get to
kind of just go out and experience
everything that you want in a very small
space and we put crying out loud in one
of the hotels or the [ __ ] aquarium in
the middle of a [ __ ] desert
percent grade-a be right there
USDA prime straight from tower that
black pepper Vegas is just one of those
things that you got to do with the right
people and it's for girls to like girls
you guys love Vegas because you get
everything for free
I got a pay for everything I'm to do
that walks into the club the bouncer
looks at me he goes $4,000
like what the [ __ ] she paid nothing is
that well your titties are different
than hers yours disgust me
what were yours oh oh you can do it
what do what what is it what is it what
Rossetti whatever super odd and weird